[Music]
people often substitute moral outrage
displayed on the internet for actual
action so there are a few instances in
which outrage and social media have led
to actual change the me2 movement is a
good example of that
we're actually seeing real meaningful
change where people who are creeps have
been fired businesses have gotten much
more serious about harassment policies
so there's been some positive aspects of
that but it is often the case that when
something rises in social media and
there's an outrage moment the people who
are the ones who really are guilty of
whatever we should be outraged about
basically get a pass if they just wait
for about 24 hours
it goes away nobody knows about it and
it moves on so a big problem with moral
outrage on the internet is that it leads
people to think they've done something
when in fact they haven't done something
and because it's sort of compelling and
exciting to stay online and display your
virtue over and over again whether
that's from one political point of view
or another political point of view
you're wasting a huge amount of time
that could actually be going towards
actual social change so you're not for
example registering people to vote you
are not thinking through a policy
concept in developing a clear policy you
are just being outraged well now maybe
not a lot of people are qualified to do
things like policy development they're
not in a position to pass laws so they
feel like they're at least doing
something but when they're doing that
over and over again what they're doing
is they're creating a feedback loop
system where the people who do have
power are probably reacting reiterative
lee to where there's loudness and
loudness is not always where the best
thinking comes through so the internet
is a wild and crazy thing a beautiful
thing it has been wonderful for some
parts of democracy but it also is a
tremendous distraction and it can also
be really dangerous in terms of leading
people to think what is not true is true
so one thing I think you have to do when
you're doing activism if you want it to
be effective is you have to actually
think about what the goal is and that
sounds really obvious but it's often the
case that activists have a sort of lofty
more fiscal like stop climate change or
stop sexual abuse those are great goals
but they're not really clear and they're
not something you can say to yourself
how am I going to get there and how am I
going to know when I've done it so it's
really important to sit down carefully
and think okay you have this big huge
goal but what are the specific
objectives that you're gonna try to
achieve and how are you going to move
towards trying to achieve those how will
we know when we're making progress I
think part of what happens where some
people and activism is they identify
with the cause in such a way that the
cause is themselves and they as long as
they're expending energy they think
they're achieving something because they
feel good about themselves because
they're getting more attention that
should not be the goal glorification of
the activists should never be the goal
it is the case that good activist
movements often have somebody
charismatic in the lead it's also often
true that that person has narcissistic
personality disorder so people who don't
need to be really careful about thinking
how do we actually get towards
meaningful goals that represent actual
social change
[Music]